hey guys how's it going of happy
holidays it's another video about the
festive season I have a hot glue gun
today we are going to decorate holiday
iPhone cases so you got two cases here I
have a really cute little folio case and
you've got that wait how is that fair on
the one side you got your right well I
just seen more like I just change son
yeah you're being is super drunk how you
what I had to feel don't touch me
got a bunch of craft supplies we all set
up those theatres chips we do not
sponsored just for fun time love casinos
Nick loves when we crunch right in the
mic further than I want this welcome I'm
not good I don't know you could just you
know why I'm a you think I got those I
already do that great I have no idea
what is happening you're blocking my
shot cuz like what is this what is this
what actually is it alright I know what
I want to know oh look this this is very
fun see Holly Jolly Christmas that's a
little aggressive you're a little
aggressive
yes Vicki no holiday decorations is to
really think outside the box I can
barely think the regular box oh my gosh
these are so super cute this is making
me so obsessed blinking don't do that
don't do that no Jenna oh my gosh these
were on sale at Target here's the thing
you're left-handed right yes doesn't
that mean you use the part of your brain
that makes you creative yeah but I'm
using my right hand right now your name
of dextrous is so that means you're
using your whole brain which means
you've made creative than me that's true
man you gotta be careful like touch me
but I didn't realize that because my my
neurons were a little slow and then it
just took me like a hurricane
what else you got on this little pack
what you got in that pack this is my
last resort suffocation no breathing
don't get I'm just I'd like to apologize
to everyone who's made it this far in
the video and nothing has happened yet
how my finger is burning hot to touch
this is this is what we can't believe it
I think I'm getting real into DIY like
doing it myself doing it yourself I need
more things okay not looking boom
surprise wonder what she's getting out
there no okay well you know you do
whatever you think that you need to do I
have no idea what I need to do cuz I
would like to start over can we start
the video over the Harry do Mulligan
what's that mean Papa my glutes and then
glide I don't think I want to do that
myself enjoy Alexa like everybody hurts
this this is like how I feel right now I
know really sad cuz I lost again at a
knock competition Alexa stop I'm gonna
get a copyright strike I just getting
into it just don't love my creative
direction here it's trash
how long will we've been rolling I've
been gluing me freaking things out for
45 days 90 days before it feels like for
freaking ever like these little gems I'm
looking for symmetry and they're hard to
match up mm symmetry
I like symmetry I like symmetry and I
like following the rules whoo you sound
like a goody two she had fun oh hey guys
you want to fold the rules and have a
fun time symmetrical fun call Jenna
I give you her number but I don't know
it you're the one number what if there's
an emergency
I guess jam some gems in I never liked
doing arts and crafts in school did you
oh of course I did
I'm right brained sometime
no brain no you're fine my mother
flaming firecrackers forever
what jeez Oh gracious glory everybody
hurts I hope you're having fun oh look
at the symmetry well it's not symmetric
as I can't find it
well are we done yet cuz yeah I could do
this all night and I'm it's already like
freakin midnight it's the morning now
alright here we go
it's an iPhone it's the case it's a
necklace it's fashion oh that's cute
mine um we'll get you through a dark
night when you walk to your car and
you're like hey this isn't fair you've
had two parts that decorate it's yeah
but it had more surface area that I had
to cover yeah but like you had more
options like I I have this I'm putting
myself in the freezer but see you in a
couple of years I'll come boot I'll go
really
Jenna's and cryofreeze let's see what
she's doing she comes out she still has
like her 2018 these are still lit kept
me warm and it actually freeze oh boy
what I'm out I'm 30 like no I'm just
just Dean they just got your nuts
this is terrible no let me see it on you
yours isn't a necklace you're a loser
come on it's lovely letter for Nikon I
say decorating together with you you
know it looks better further away I've
been looking at it close up I'm like oh
but wow me from far away it's glamorous
mmm super good super glam hey I can let
you borrow it because Jay how many songs
have we sang in like like everything
that we do there is a song for it mine's
better I won this competition okay well
we're not this isn't a competition I
want unless you guys want to make it
I won let us know in the comments below
who you think is the best I will also
put a pool right up here you could do
that yeah my question let us know whose
you think it's better guys please do you
think it's a necklace
it's a carrier who do you think Janice
looks better it's a noisemaker you can
assure that you see close-up you see how
good this looks
yeah that looks great like mine even
opens up I think look that that's the
disadvantage you chose the case you gave
me this one look at also blinks your
idiot you gave me your owning the
Christmas spirit
you're a bridge no I love Christmas but
you admit that you took the case that
you knew you could make better than mine
joke's on you because the pool is gonna
be like Jenna's looks beautiful get in
hurry Oh cause I'm crunching I'm gonna
send this clip to Matt he's I like
action 5 a task for you oh no very
important go find something super
crunchy eat it and then tweet it to at
nature he's not gonna be happy and Merry
Christmas he's not gonna like that at
all it's gonna be the best thing ever
[Music]
instrument or Enya's video that's bad
for the microphone you're ruining iron
Christmas Christmas has been ruined ok
guys thanks for watching happy holidays
you guys decide to make a festive
holiday case for a friend or for
yourself please tweet it to me or Jenna
tweeted to us both we want to see them
and let us know whose case you like in
the best and yes I may have had a slight
advantage I didn't even realize
hahahaha buddy why let's stop this
Sothis right now we're done
[Music]
you